GREG IVANOV: Hi.
Thanks, [? Albert. ?]
My name is Greg,
and I'm Partner Development
Manager at Google Play,
and I lead a lot of our VR and
AR focused efforts in Europe.
So this talk will be so
philosophical a little bit,
a little bit practical.
And the idea is to give you a
taste of our vision for what
we now call immersive
computing, which we see now
emerging through
the frameworks of AR
and VR, and perhaps
most importantly,
give you a little
bit of inspiration
and a way of thinking
around this topic
and what this might mean
for you as a developer,
and then explain
some of the tools
that we have in place today to
help you succeed in this area.
So let's start with the vision.
So ultimately, this comes
down to making technology work
a lot more like we do.
And does anyone know roughly
what year this photo's from?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GREG IVANOV: No.
'40s.
So that's a computer
punch card from the '40s.
So that's obviously not the most
frictionless and intuitive way
of interacting with a computer.
I think you'll all
agree with that.
And so, I think it's fair to
say that smartphones were truly
the first breakthrough in terms
of innovation and interfaces
and accessibility with
computers and what they can do.
And still, the level of
abstraction remains, right?
So when you call a
friend on your phone,
you don't really see them like
you see them in real life.
You see this flat, lifeless
version of them on the screen.
And equally, when you're
looking for restaurant,
your phone doesn't really
walk you to the restaurant.
You still have to look at your
phone and see those blue dots,
and then find a way
of navigating that.
It's not ideal.
It's getting better,
but, it's not ideal.
So with immersive
computing, we're
saying that instead of
staring at our screens
and constantly
checking our phones,
we'll be able to interact
with the world and computers
in a more natural way.
We'll be able to
hold up our heads
to the real and virtual
worlds around us.
OK.
That's kind of the
high level philosophy
as to how we think about this.
So what is immersive computing?
So the way we think of this
is really as a spectrum,
with AR and VR as
two points on it.
So on the very right, we
have virtual reality, which
is fully computer-generated.
On the very left,
you have reality,
or you can call it real
reality, as what we
are taking part in right here.
And in the middle, sort
of the middle part,
is augmented reality,
and this layer
of computer-generated
reality that
comes on top of our real world.
Another way to put
it is virtual reality
can take you anywhere, as
this beautiful image shows,
and augmented reality can
bring anything to you.
So this is all
kind of intuitive.
So let's take a look at some
of the efforts and the latest
things that we've done in
the augmented reality space.
So if you think
back 10 years ago,
that was one of the
first Android devices.
Computers as phones have become
a lot more powerful and sort of
interesting in terms
of what they can do,
yet their understanding,
contextual understanding
of the world around them,
has become pretty limited.
With AR, this equation will
be changed dramatically.
This will really bring
the next big shift
in terms of computers
understanding
the world around them in a
completely different way.
So at the most basic
fundamental level,
this is about providing
timely and relevant
digital information in the
context of the real world.
So here, you've got an
example of da Vinci's
"Lady with a Ermine," where
the very first version
of the painting didn't
even have the ermine.
And then, you can
see the progression
to the very final version, where
actually the face of the lady
has changed dramatically.
And that's a really rich and
interesting digital contextual
information that you just
wouldn't have access to
in the same way without
this AR technology.
So what are some of
the other use cases?
Well, shopping is really
obvious and fun one,
and kind of immediately
practically useful,
where you can essentially
overlay any digital object
into a physical
space and see what
this is going to look like.
You can learn about
real-life objects
in a completely new and
interactive way, which
is kind of shown by this
high-end coffee machine, where
you can learn and
interact in this way.
So games is obviously a huge
use case, and as we all know,
"Pokemon Go" has really
planted the seed in this space,
and we're only going to
see more and more amazing
stuff coming in terms
of gaming and AR.
And last but not
least, the example
that I used earlier in
terms of navigation,
it becomes a contextual
window into the world,
where instead of
holding down your phone
and figuring out how
to relate to it, how
to relate to your external
world as an external object,
you will actually be using
the phone as a window
and be able to see contextual
information around you
and navigational prompts in
a much more intuitive way.
So at Google, as
a lot of you know,
we started our AR efforts
with Tango in 2014.
Now Tango was a hardware play,
as intrinsically everything
hardware, it's a lot harder
to scale and distribute.
So two months ago,
we announced ARCore,
which is all about AR
at the scale of Android.
So let's take a quick
look at what this can do.
So motion tracking.
This is a really
fundamental aspect of AR.
So it knows where your
phone is in space.
Secondly, environmental
understanding.
So as in this case, it knows
that a table is indeed a table,
and that you can
place objects on it.
The same goes for
walls and ceilings.
Light estimation is
super important too,
so that, as in this
example, the object knows
when the light in the
room is switched off,
and it can adjust accordingly.
Right now, this is running
on pixel devices and Samsung,
with more OEMs coming
on-board very quickly,
and we're expecting over 100
million devices very soon.
The way we think
of this is really
as both a feature
and a foundation,
meaning that we
certainly hope that you
are able to integrate
ARCore and AR
experiences within
your existing apps,
and we hope that
this will give birth
to a whole new types of
experiences that are native AR.
Let's take a look at some
of this in action now.
Want to play the video?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
Amazing.
So that's CoreAR.
And let's move
onto VR now and see
what we've done there in the
last couple of months or so.
So last year in
November, we launched
Daydream, which is all about
basically high-end premium VR
experiences with the
scale of Android,
interactive experiences,
and comfortable headsets.
Then this year, we've
announced even more devices
that are supporting
Daydream, so that you
can use Daydream on almost
any high-end Android device,
most notably Samsung S8 is now
supporting Daydream as well,
and we're expecting
even more OEMs to come
onboard in the next year or so.
In terms of software and
hardware-- and by the way,
the new Google Daydream View,
with more colors and even more
comfort.
In terms of software, we have
even more apps than before.
So the momentum is quite strong.
You, know let's keep in mind
that developing for VR--
and let's be honest
about this-- is still
very hard and quite expensive.
So we're trying to be very
careful as to how we bring this
to market.
Having said that, all
Android developers
are now able to develop
for VR, and we're
seeing a lot more
organic titles coming
into the store, which we're
supporting through featuring.
In terms of the product
itself, and what Daydream
looks like inside, we've
made it even easier
to discover, interact with,
and share experiences in VR.
So let's take a look
at what this means.
In terms of discovery,
Daydream Home
has an updated look, with these
new tabs of the top, which
makes it even easier to engage
users and keep users in VR
for longer, therefore
kind of developing
this daily use of VR, which
we think is so, so important
by taking it sort of mainstream.
Dashboard is extremely
powerful as well.
So this enables you to interact
with your Android notifications
without having to
take off the headset.
Casting, that was
one of the most
asked for software features.
So the power of
Chromecast and Daydream
now enables you to stream
or cast your VR experience
in the headset onto
any large screen,
therefore making the
experience a lot more social.
Screenshot and video
capture is also here,
so that you can now
share your experiences
on all the usual
channels, making
it more accessible for users
to see what you're actually
up to in your VR environment.
Last but not least, and this is
a really cool one, YouTube call
watching.
So you can actually
experience YouTube on Daydream
concurrently with your friends.
So we've talked a lot
about the philosophy,
and what we've done with AR
and VR on the product side,
and I want to leave you with
kind of a taste of the future.
So this convergence
of AR and VR,
those two points in the
spectrum, is pretty inevitable.
And we think this will
enable a new type of devices
to come to the market.
First one such device is the
Lenovo All-In-One headset
that will come to the
market early next year.
This will use part
of the technology,
such as motion tracking
and depth perception,
and it will be a busy
running Daydream,
so you can interact
with your VR experiences
in a more richer and
kind of untethered way,
with more functionality
and more freedom to move.
And beyond that, we've all
heard the term mixed reality.
And so, let's see
what shape that takes.
Most likely, in the form
of devices that will
combine both AR and VR in one.
And so, immersive computing,
and its future and present,
frankly, is pretty exciting,
and we're only just
at the very beginning.